Taiwan's main city of Taipei was unbelievably beautiful and easy to get around.
You can pick up an EasyCard at any of the Metro stations,...
...and then use it to not only ride the Metro but pick up a YouBike.
Any of these city-owned bicycles strewn literally everywhere throughout Taipei.
This is a really great way to get through the city and see the local temples.
You can even take the bikes downtown and park them at the night park...
...or ride them to the zoo...
...and then take the glass-bottom gondola up to Maokong mountain for a day of teatime.
Why stop there?
Why not go out and get a traditional Taiwanese knife massage and balance your chi...
...or just ride it up to the view of Elephant Mountain.